.
JESSE?
>> Jesse: GREAT SUNSET.
THANK YOU.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> OH!
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WOW.
YOU GOT THE VIDEO?
>> I GOT IT.
>> HERE IT IS.
>> OH, MAN.
>> THAT'S OUR POOL.
THAT'S OUR DECK.
THAT WAS MY HOUSE.
MY HOUSE IS GONE.
>> Jesse: A FOX NEWS ALERT, ONE
OF THE LARGEST SEARCH AND RESCUE
MISSIONS IN AMERICAN HISTORY IS
UNDERWAY AFTER HURRICANE IAN
DECIMATED MOVING UP THE EAST
COAST.
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS SAYS THE
SITUATION IS REALLY BAD.
>> THE AMOUNT OF WATER THAT'S
BEEN RISING, WILL LIKELY
CONTINUE TO RISE TODAY, EVEN AS
THE STORM IS PASSING, IS
BASICALLY A 500-YEAR FLOOD
EVENT.
>> Jesse: FIRST RESPONDERS ARE
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK.
HUNDREDS HAVE BEEN RESCUED SINCE
THE STORM HIT.
HERE'S NASSAU COUNTY DEPUTIES
SAVING TWO PEOPLE STRANDED ON A
SAILBOAT IN THE STORM.
>> HOLD ON, HOLD ON!
HOLD!
>> Jesse: ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE STATE, NAPLES FIREFIGHTERS
RESCUED A WOMAN TRAPPED IN
FLOODWATERS.
WATCH.
>> Jesse: IT'S ALL HANDS ON
DECK.
WE'RE SEEING THE BEST SIDE OF
PEOPLE COME OUT IN THE FACE OF
TRAGEDY.
A GOOD SAMARITAN USED HIS JET
SKI TO HELP FIREFIGHTERS WITH
RESCUES.
THE CAMERAMAN STOPPED WHAT HE
WAS DOING MID-REPORT TO HELP
PEOPLE ACROSS THE WATER.
>> THIS ONE IS AS BIG AS
FLORIDA.
THAT IS MASSIVE.
>> KEEP GOING.
KEEP GOING.
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
>> IT'S AN ENORMOUS -- AN
ENORMOUS STORM.
I'M FINE.
JUST HELPING SOME PEOPLE THROUGH
THE WATER HERE.
THAT'S OUR CAMERA OPERATOR GLEN
ELLIS OUT THERE I THINK YOU CAN
SEE TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
ARE WADING AWAY FROM THEIR
HOMES.
WE'VE SPOKEN TO A COUPLE OF
THEM.
>> Jesse: A MAN WALKED THROUGH
FLOODWATERS TO SAVE A STRANDED
CAT.
>> KITTY.
>> Jesse: FLORIDA IS NO STRANGER
TO HURRICANES, BUT THIS ONE IS
DIFFERENT.
FORT MYERS BEACH OFFICIALS SAY
THERE'S NOTHING TO COME BACK TO.
90% OF THE CITY IS DESTROYED.
90%.
THERE'S AT LEAST 15 KNOWN DEATHS
ACROSS THE STATE, BUT THAT
NUMBER IS EXPECTED TO GO UP.
BIDEN SAYS THIS MAY BE ONE OF
THE DEADLIEST STORMS EVER.
>> THIS COULD BE THE DEADLIEST
HURRICANE IN FLORIDA'S HISTORY.
THE NUMBERS ARE STILL UNCLEA